He takes test any committee comes it is either a
test and punishment for the Prophet of high
Taqwa it was punishment it was test and pass test any
good thing happen to inzal it is either a
reward and
test wealth can be reward and it can be
test for you any good thing happen it is either a
reward and test for you from Allah they pray give
me wealth and take a
fail in this world they get what they want luxury bakhra it is nothing but
charity test contentment
test chin a
test many time we human being we
complain to Allah Subhan tala we pray
Allah Subhan Allah answer prayer Allah in
Quran you ask me and I we answer prayer I am praying
everyday Allah is not answering it so
contact Allah you pray to me answer prayer but we find out more we pray but nothing happens
Allah says in the Quran in Sura Baqarah
chapter number  Two verses number 216 You may like a
thing which is not good for you and you may
hate a thing which is good for you You know nothing
but Allah knows For
example there is a young boy now 20 years old He is
praying Ya Allah Subhan Taala give me a bed Bad bad
motor Bad motor fast motor Pray Ya Allah no moral damp so Allah subhan and mere bani aner aar baan aanvi
Morak bad banda he is a
good person he is asking for something good if he does not know so
Allah gave not answering and me too
People alla bakr chatter aba hipak se Allah give rope so
go to and from Ya
Allah got many people not
partner with Allah They ask me what wealth
Allah gave it is nothing but
taste for them and they are not giving grave
so should never be there Allah gave alat na
haram
Iran kill na
I will kill myself, I will be forgiven ...
Well, we are praying that Allah
Subhan Taala make not us the cause to take a
burden on us. We can only believe that
Allah has the last word
and worship Him alone is the creator and
purpose of existence. We worship Allah Subhan Taala
and no one else can give us this life and test for us after following the
commandment and be satisfied. We can always give you a true message. We
thank Allah
Subhan Taala. Normally we complain that we don't have this. We do this. The
most important thing
for living is what someone tells us,
food, someone tells us, water is the most
important thing. If you don't have air for
a few minutes, you will do that. Thank Allah Subhan Taala. If you don't have air for a few minutes, you will get it for
free. So what should we
reflect on? Allah Subhan Taala is the
last
word and this word is what is mentioned
in Ibrahim (Islam) chapter number 14 verse
number  32 33 Allah created the heaven and the
earth and let water come from the sky with it he has
given fruits he has caused the ship to
sail with the commandment of Allah Allah created the
reverse to flow for the human being he has
made the sun and the moon for you he has made the
night and day for you so this creation the
world is for the human being full world
Allah
created all human
beings and it is our duty that we have to
thank Allah Subhan Ta'ala for the
Niyama and besides thanking it is a duty
that we take care of these things is the reason
Allah Subhan Ta'ala has given animals but
killing
animals is prohibited killing is
prohibited
salam they do not kill animals for target
practice yes for food among the halal animals
by Allah given
permission that you can have with the way Allah has
given you and the Prophet has given us target
practice and we find  Many people they want to
conquer the Niyama they do target practice
and they want to put the head of the animal in the
drawing room Allah cut the mountain we want to
conquer the mount go on Mount Everest how many people do every year
in trying to climb
the mountain you want to conquer it thank Allah
sun ta'ala for the
Niyama even two Allah says in the Quran they have been
created for you to carry loads but even
two they have been created for you we have to love them we have
to respect them there are several Sahi Hadith several it is mentioned in
Sahi Bukhari
that number three is that the person who gave water
to a thirsty dog ​​by going in the well ba
carrying the water in the socks and because of that he was called Jannah the Hadith
in Sahi Bukhari
and number four is that just because she gave a
thirsty dog ​​she was called Jannah and Saba and we get rewarded even
for giving  water to a
dog he said yes why not equal the animal which
is prohibited to come in our house even if you give
water to that animal allah
will reward you for that and that once an odd lady
she tied a cat and did not give it
food so allah put in hell why did she not give
a food at least you let it go free she
fed on the road and then put in one of the
posters the in action so we have to love
and take care of animals in the west we can kill them
for necessity but not
unnecessary kill the plants in the rain pray do not chop
down trees do not burn the
crops so listen the creation of allah
sula
and allah se quran in
aayah chhat number 100 allah se allah te an othe
of steed of
var han wa ala th and ala continuance na ala set
hse skamm of hu cloud of dust they re de
enter
ami dhikr alla a  Oath of this is the state of war they are without any fear just because the
master commands them the pan's rider for the
sake of the master they enter to the same they are their weapon
respecting the weapon the steed keeps on
going because he wants to obey
the master Allah is taking oath of this
face and in ending he says but man is
grateful that he should obey the master Allah is taking oath of this face and in ending he says but man is grateful that he should obey the master Allah is taking oath of this face and in ending he says it is the
duty of every human being to
reflect on the purpose of
creation we have been
cursed Allah and he is forgiving himself just it is the duty
of every human being that they should worship Allah
and no one and this life remains the
test after if they follow the
commandment they will die if they die and go and
have to take
0 Muslim is the best of all people one by one all people never do it fully know what is
good and forbidden what is
in Allah it is the duty of every
Muslim if you know the purpose of
creation you have to tell it to others but should worship
no one Allah this life is for you after all
invite people to do the same
and prevent them from going astray
it is the duty of every
Muslim dawah kasri if you don't do it fully
and we don't present your Muslim is the
best of all people who are in Allah now we move
on to the question and answer
session before we begin let me lay down the
rules so that we can have the session in a very
smooth
fashion please form a Q at one of the four
mics provided to  You have one mic in the
ladies section and there are three mics in the
gents section one at the back side one on my
right and one here on my
left while posing the questions please
state your name and
profession please note that this is a question
time not a lecture time so be precise and
to the point when you pose your question I
request the volunteers who are handling the mic
to give preference to our non Muslim
brothers who would be in the queue while posing
the questions please bring the non Muslim
brothers at the front preference is given to
the non Muslim brothers to pose the
questions good evening doctor
my name is Robert I am doing BDS in
Chanai Savita Dental College as Doctor Sakir said I am a
unique creator there is only one second thing you said I have created human beings
out of love that I have created wealth, happiness
and
weakness in my body  Thus similarly in Christianity they
believe God is one and second point God is divided
human being or all point is the same thing less thing than God
so I just want to have
answer from you I don't know why Christianity says God is
one and
God loves the
creation and he further said what is the
difference or the difference between Islam and creation is the
most convincing you
think to you other than Islam any other
type of worship is not acceptable is very
good question now the question has come to first just
block statements is question
mark its question its statement we have to
try and find the question what is the difference
between Islamic form of worship is compared to
other form of worship so if any Christian says
God is one Christianity says that God
Also loves Islam says God is one Islam
says God loves the creation Islam says worship
what is the difference between the
worship of Islam and Christianity and what
is the uniqueness about Islam as we know it
mainly talking about Christianity brother
on the face of it if you
read the Quran correctly and the interpretation
I gave in my
talk and if you read the Bible correctly with the
correct interpretation we believe that
Jesus is one and the master
messenger alla su no muslim if not ins up we believe he is one and the master messenger
we believe he is the master
messenger we
believe he gave life to give us god
permission but there are many
christians who say that
jesus christ peace be upon him he
claims
divinity
and what they practice the difference between
That's why so many Christians say that Jesus Christ has become peace. He came down so when they say
God is one, they say
Jesus Christ has become God which we
Muslims take objection to. There is
not a single unequivocal statement in the
complete Bible. Jesus Christ has become one of them. He says I am God
and they worship me.
So the form of worship for normal Christians
is worshipping Jesus Christ. Peace be upon him. And
I repeat my statement there is not a
single unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible. Jesus Christ has become one of them. He says I am God
and they worship me. If any
Christian can show me any unequivocal
statement in the Bible. He says I am
God and they worship me. I am Dr.
Zakir Naik. I am ready to accept Christianity
today. I am ready to put my head on the
guillotine
[praise]
I don't speak on behalf of my other Muslim
brothers because if you read the Bible it is
mentioned in the  Gospel of John Chapter 14
Verse 28 Jesus Christ Peace Be Upon Him said that
my Father is greater than I Gospel of
John Chapter 10 Verse 29 My Father
is greater than all Gospel of Matthew Chapter
12 Verse 28 I with the spirit of
God cast out a devil Gospel of Luke Chapter
11 Verse 20 I with the finger of
God cast out a devil Gospel of John Chapter 5 Verse
30 I can of my own
self do nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will but
the will of my Father any one who says I seek not
my will but the will of the mighty God is a
Muslim there for I said in my talk that
Jesus Christ Peace Be Upon Him was a
Muslim Quran says that in Sura Al Imran
Chapter 3 Verse 52 it is further mentioned in the Gospel  Gospel
of John Chapter number 17 verse number this is
life itself so that you may know Jesus
Christ whom you have sent it is mentioned in the
Gospel of John Chapter number 14 verse number
24 the words you hear are not mine but my
fathers who have sent me it is clearly mentioned in
the Book of Acts Chapter number two verse number
22 the men of Israel listen to this Jesus of
Nazar a man approved of God among you by
wonders and miracles which God did by him
and you witness to it a man approved
of God among you by wonders and miracles
which God did by him and you witness to it
so Jesus Christ peace be upon him he was
one of the mightiest messengers of God but he never claimed divinely he never said you should
worship me but unfortunately the Christian
church does teach that
salvation the Bible also talks about heaven  Talks
about hell but the purpose of
existence is not mentioned in detail it is not mentioned at all except that it is mentioned in chapter number
15 only from chapter 15 that if Jesus Christ peace be upon him he died
for your sins your faith is in him
and everything is in him that means Jesus
Christ peace be upon him he died for your
sins according to Paul and they
quote the verse of the Bible gospel number 3 verse
number 16 that for God soul of the world that he gave his only begotten son who so believe
in him shall not die but ever
lasting life so the
concept of salvation according to the church
is that you believe Jesus Christ peace be upon him he died
for your sins and you shall go to heaven you shall go to paradise which
is not mentioned because
the word begun from Gospel of John chapter
number 3 verse number 16 has  Been thrown out by the
scholar of the highest eminent from
the RSV Revised Standard Version of the Bible
as a construction as a fabrication as an
interpolation so what they are following is more political
Christianity but Jesus Christ
peace be his own man said one a person approach him
in the Gospel of Matthew chapter number 19
verse number 16 and 17 that good master what
good things shall I do so that I shall gain
spiritual life what good thing shall I do so that I shall go
to heaven then Jesus
Christ peace be his reply why the cost me
good there is no good accept one the mighty
God and if you want to enter heavenly life you
follow the commandments he has set if you want to go
to heaven you want to go to heaven you
believe died for since he said that he said
follow the commandments and Jesus must p said
It is mentioned in the Gospel of Matthew chapter number
five verse number 17 to 20. I have come not to
destroy the law of the prophets. I have come
not to destroy but
fulfill only the law of heaven and pass away not one but all shall be passed away
from the law but all shall be fulfilled. And who soever shall
keep the
commandments and teach men to do so shall be
called great in the kingdom of heaven and who soever shall
break one of the least commandments will be called least
in the kingdom of heaven
unless your righteousness exceeds the reach of the
sky and the farce in no way shall you enter
into paradise. If you want to be a good
Christian you have to follow all the commandments. There is only
one God. You shall not do idol worship.
Moses and his people be upon him. So we analyze if we do a
research of the Bible
scripture but
not
all.  There is
no statement in Babylon. They are doing what they are becoming because those who say that God is
three in one. The word Trinity does
exist anyway in the Bible. The close
statement is in the first Epistle of John. Chapter
number five verse number seven says that there are
three that were born in heaven: the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Ghost. And these three are one. And this verse
of the Bible by some of the highest
Christian scholars in the Revised Standard
Version of the Bible they throw this verse out
of the Bible as interpolation, as fabrication,
as assumption. So the verse which comes close to
Trinity does mention Trinity but comes close
is thrown out by the scholars of
Christianity as a fabrication. So if we
analyze, if you want to check what is right
in the Bible, here is the Furqan, this is the
criterion, it will tell you what is right, what is right,
and if you compare it with this, and even today
if you read the Bible, the Bible  Never
claim that Jesus is God Peace be upon him it says
you should worship only one God and when
Jesus Christ Peace be upon him that is the
first of the commandments it is mentioned in the
Gospel of Mark chapter number 12 verse
number 29 says shema Israel i mal the laad our God is one
laad so problem is if you
read the Bible its purpose of Christ it is when
the Christian church took up teaching of every
pal and you believe Jesus cant and you will go to heaven then you do anything if you repay or do anything if paid for then I can eat anything
for example someone tells me to go to a
restaurant eat what you want I
paid your bill I can eat anything chicken mutton
biryani anything I can eat so if Jesus
Christ Peace be upon him I am dead for my
sins then you can commit any  Sin and you will go to
heaven only have to believe that he died
for your sins so this is the concept of the
church which is not what the Bible mentions and
you can refer to my video cassette
similarities between Islam and
Christianity which gives the similarities that the
reason I say that Jesus Christ told nothing
but Islam that is submitting your will
to Almighty God
[praise]
can next question from Badar please
state your name in
profession re super at outset I am
extremely delighted to be here even though I am
not a
Muslim in the Old Testament of the Bible it is not as God
createdtoken after that God
createddocumentsfragment
universe I cant in Bible and Quran are say
please explain why do I have name and
can I repeat what now Quran karali name first
and ran
Quran number I thra number sun state ya se  21
2 number
21 no in sara number s i th but in chapter 21
verse 22 god controls the
universe so that goes along science a yes brother asked a question he said that he has read
the
bible he cited a few verses of the bible
and of the quran he does not give the reference he said that
the bible says that almighty god
created kor
on the first day and then if you
read in genesis chapter number
one verse number 13 to 19 it says almighty god
created jnt this goes along science i do agree with you it goes along
science and i had a
debate with doctor william kaimal in usa
doctor william kaimal he is a missionary and a
medical doctor and got a phd writing a
book against the quran and in that debate on
bible say i powr soi pralam in
bible when set lmao god controls yrs
Reading Bible I read Bible sa
ran lamgad control yrs yup ting I
heard that and I gave reference
chapter 21 verse 22 the reference is rang ya
reference ya the real reference is chapter 21 verse
22 verse 33 not ran I am speaking from
memory I am not a
computer I will give the reply brother after I
reply what ever query you have no
problem brother you ask brother you ask the
question let me reply after I finish my
reply you can ask another 20 question
but you ask the question
I am listening to you carefully now you listen to my answer and
after I finish my answer if have any query you can ask I will give
nuff time cherman n agree I
request him to give you time because you are
delighted to come here we are
more delighted you are
Here the Badar said from the Quran in these verses
21 22 it is exactly verse 33 that the sun rotates while following
each verse of Quran it is
not in motion and this mistake was taken from
Bangladesh said if a book is not rotated then how can we solve this
problem by following each
verse of Quran the sun rotates and turns around then the sun and the moon rotate and turns around then the sun and the moon
rotate and turns around and turns around and turns around I was
in school I had learnt
that the sun was
stationary it did not rotate on its own because it
revolves in the universe two solar
systems are revolving but I one I passed my
school in 1982 I had learnt the sun was not stationary
but this  Verse of the Quran says the Arabic
word Ya Boon is derived from the word Saha which
describes the motion of a moving body if I
use this Arabic wad Saha for a person on
the floor it will not mean he is rolling it will mean he is
walking and running if I use this
Arabic wad for a person in the water it will not mean he is
floating it will mean he is
swimming one Allah use this word for a
moving body it does mean he is flying it means he
is rotating about one's axis so Quran
says the sun and the moon besides revolve they are also
rotating about one's axis one I
read the verse of the Quran I said but I
read in my school book the sun does not rotate
today science advance and we come to know we can have
the image of the sun on table top and we see
that the sun has got black spots and those
black spots take about 25 days to
complete and notation indicating  The Sun takes up to
25 days to complete one lesson so what I was
in school in 1982 today say it is the
color Quran mentions 20 years back 1400 years back what I was in
school 20 years
back Quran say what is the color first I doubted it was very rich
Quran is written Quran is
not my science book was
color and Taslima Nasreen would put the word meaning
inside I don't know she knows Arabic can
she read English English translation can't say that she
agree that when the Quran says the Sun is
round that's assumption so her
assumption is the color Alhamdulillah Quran is
not the
color and I do agree with you that Allah
Sun Taala He controls this universe that is the reason
according to Francis Bacon Francis
Bacon great philosopher he said little knowledge of
science makes you an believer but in path knowledge of
science makes you a believer  In One God Hope The
Answer Question
[Praise]
Do you have a way You have a way Most welcome
back Sir I love you Sir I'm not
my number No problem I never knew I'd just have to tell the
right thing If you have given something I'd refer someone up
Corrected
you I set you have to know by heart my
computer my computer But I tired it I in my
number
sun's r